we are heading into restricted territory
foreign journalists require permission
to visit the northern part of reclined
state this is where Myanmar security
forces launched a brutal crackdown
against the mainly Muslim Rohingya
minority in August 2017 soldiers and
Buddhist mobs were accused of raping
killing and setting fire to ruin gir
homes the Buddhist majority Myanmar
government said it was responding to
attacks and killings by an armed group
called the Arakawa hinga Salvation Army
at the UN's highest court Myanmar has
denied charges of genocide and has been
ordered by the International Court of
Justice to prevent further violence
while the case is being heard on this
tightly controlled highly choreographed
trip the Myanmar government tries to
show that all is well here in village
after village row hinga were brought to
meet journalists in classrooms under the
watchful eye of government minders on
camera their answers seemed scripted we
have three communities here living like
a family that's why I don't think we
will be affected by conflict off camera
they were only slightly less reticent
telling us they feared violence could
flare again it was impossible to speak
to anyone without being overheard by
police in another village we were made
to see government cash being handed out
to Roja local administrators say it's to
help the villagers rebuilt their damaged
homes this loss still hasn't been
repaired more than two years after the
latest campaign of violence against the
raw anger started and you can see all
around there's clear evidence of
destruction by fire this place of
worship would have served the people of
this community who at one point numbered
around five thousand people now they're
only two hundred living here around
three quarters of a million Rohingya
fled to Bangladesh and remain there no
we do not think the repatriation is a
failure because as you know we have two
reception centres and we have a
transition camp we are always ready to
receive them we even plan to open
kindergartens many rights groups
say conditions in Myanmar don't
guarantee a safe return for the row
hinga the last attempt to repatriate
3,000 refugees from Bangladesh in August
failed because thorough hinga refused to
return saying they feared further
attacks if they did the Myanmar
government wants them to accept
alternative identification documents
which rights activists say deprives them
of their rights rohan understand that
ulterior motive of Miyama government
what they are doing they are forcibly
degrading their citizenship status so
Rohingyas are not willing to be degraded
they are the rahaga have little to
return to they face government
restrictions on travel employment even
family planning many doubt the situation
will change anytime soon had it done
like this the job of leadership is try
to control it
instead what the civil and the military
leaders are firming it you know this
kind of populist wave to get lateral
supports it's very disgraceful thing
until then the row hinga will remain one
of the world's most persecuted
minorities all right and go live now to
Florence who's in Yangon now in Myanmar
and Florence very few people seem to be
convinced by the efforts being made by
the Myanmar government that everything
is ok in Rakhine State and and we get
news of more fighting how widespread is
that kind of incident that we've just
reported in which some people died some
were injured died including a child
that's right now this it's fighting
between the Myanmar military and the our
economy this is an ethnic armed group
that was that started in - that was
formed in 2009 and they say they're
fighting for the ethnic Rakhine the
rakaia another minority in Myanmar but
they're the majority population in
Rakhine State and they are mainly
Buddhists and they were also accused of
being part of Buddhas mobs that carried
out attacks against the Rohingya in 2017
now the fighting is taking place in
mainly Murrell township and also in
northern recline and where we were and
several townships are under an internet
shutdown now the latest incidents from
what we've heard from the accounts we've
heard from the military spokesman as
well as from the politicians in return
state and a row hinga activist the
rahega appear to have been caught in
crossfire in the fighting between the
our economy and the Myanmar military but
it still shows that the situation there
is very fluid now the Myanmar government
has been ordered by the International
Court of Justice while its case against
genocide is being hurt to take measures
to prevent further killing off the raw
anger but it appears that if such
fighting is going on that they are
unable to do so and the raheem de many
of whom we've spoken to say they remain
fearful now and they say that as long as
they don't have citizenship and as long
as they don't have rights really there's
nothing to return to martine ok florence
thank you for that florence lui there
live in Yangon in Myanmar